are you meeting guys on apps are you
still doing that because the last time
you were in you said you were on
that celebrity app what is that called
raya or something right
yeah i'm still on that yeah are you
meeting any celebrities
yeah i am i'm definitely matching with
some i recently changed my picture on
there and boy did that make a difference
i
i had a picture of me doing stand-up
where i looked i thought it looked like
really i definitely looked hot like body
face hair loved it good good outfit but
i'm kind of standing like
like a badass and just doing stand-up
and i wasn't getting
many matches but i was like this is what
i do why don't why aren't
why is anyone responding this and my
girlfriends looked in we're like no
no one wants that no one no guys want a
girl that's like a badass on stage like
just
like it looks like you're up there
talking about their dicks and so
i changed it to this like gentler
picture where i'm just very
open and quiet and just vulnerable and
like i look kind of wet
yeah and um oh boy i'm getting so many
matches it's changed everything
so i just have to deny who i am and
i'll find love the secret to getting a
man is to deny who you are
and to act like you're a demure almost
vulnerable
and a needy woman girl
be a handmade yes yes very submissive
yeah i've learned that men don't really
like a a yappy broad and that's kind of
my
my thing you know i talk a lot yeah you
do
talk yeah yeah that's right you make a
living
what about these celebrities are you
hooking up with a-list celebrities
b-list celebrities who are you meeting
on this thing
i'm i mean i'm sw i see the the a-list
celebrities on there and it's so funny
because you you
you heart them and then you wait and you
then it it lets you know if they hearted
you and then it's like
you matched and so i'm always like
holding my breath as i like press
heart on like you know one of the
spidermen
let's say you know right and um and
there was one instance where i was like
please please i hearted i was like
please please please as i was saying
that i was like
eating a a bowl of hummus with my
fingers and like licking it being like
please and like dropping it on my shirt
and i was like
who am i to be like yeah you deserve
this
so there's there's times where i'm like
who do i think i am but
you know there's i have matched with
some guys on there but
what happens is some of them are fans
and
that's all they are and when you get
that you're just like do you want to
[ __ ] me or do you just want to
talk about you just want to tell your
friends that you you you chatted with me
you know